please donate to give directly the
non-profit letting you send cash
directly to the world's poorest families
when you donate to give directly.org
Pacman a generous donor will match your
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
makes a perfect holiday gift help us
reach fifteen thousand dollars by the
end of the year using the link below
well ladies and gentlemen let the
insanity begin Donald Trump's tax
returns have been released and now we
are all going to be pouring over them
like the wannabe accountants that we all
are when covet hit we all became
epidemiologists on Twitter and now we
will all be tax accountants and tax
attorneys of course now I'm exaggerating
a little bit but much anticipated I mean
listen it took years to get these things
so we are sure as hell going to be
taking advantage of looking at these the
New York Times reporting Trump tax
returns released by house Democrats the
publication of former president Trump's
private tax documents come amid
questions about why did the IRS fail to
fully audit him during his presidency
despite his claims which we call lies I
call untrue claims lies
particularly when you know they're
untrue
um that he was under audit I encourage
you to check out the entire New York
Times article as we speak
um the documents are being analyzed now
there's a good CBS News piece about what
is it that tax professionals are looking
for
um what do the returns actually show
about his finances is one question and
this comes to how wealthy is he what
assets does he have what asset values
does he claim is there evidence of tax
fraud and all of the other things that
we have been talking about what do the
tax returns show about the amount of tax
that he pays that piece we had a report
on from the house Ways and Means
Committee based on the underlying
documents now we're getting the
underlying documents we know he paid
very very little in taxes claimed losses
some years paid zero some years got a
refund some years so that's going to be
a big area of focus how much money has
Trump actually made
including from being famous that's a
question that will potentially be
answered by the tax returns how
charitable is Donald Trump and then some
of these I don't think these are really
the questions like how lucrative is it
to be a real estate developer it's more
like how sketchy are Trump's sources of
financing I think that those are far far
far more interesting questions CNN has
an early report on what is in there and
of course the the one piece we learned
right away Donald Trump pays very little
in federal taxes despite the fact that
we know that he uh continue to enrich
himself while he was President of the
United States CNN writing the returns
long shrouded in secrecy were released
today by the house Ways and Means
Committee they confirm a report from The
Joint Committee on taxation that Trump
claimed large losses before and
throughout his presidency that he
carried forward to reduce or partially
eliminate his tax burden for example in
2015 he carried forward a 105
million dollar loss and in 2016 a 73
million dollar loss CNN is reviewing the
thousands of pages of these tax returns
I think by uh early next week of course
if not later today we are going to have
far more detailed uh information about
what is in these uh tax returns also
interesting this paragraph here included
with the committee's report was an
analysis of the numbers from each of the
six Trump tax returns by the nonpartisan
joint committee on taxation remember
they found that Trump paid 750 dollars
in tax in 2017 nothing in 2020
and a combined 1.1 million in federal
income taxes in 2018 and
2019. Trump regularly claimed huge
operating losses which you are allowed
to carry forward so the big takeaways
the big questions in no particular order
what will we learn from the tax returns
about Trump's wealth about Trump's debts
about Trump's uh possible tax fraud
question number one question number two
is Trump nearly as wealthy as he claims
to be I think we know the answer is no
uh what sorts of sketchy lending and
debt sources does Donald Trump have that
may have even been a conflict of
interest while he was President of the
United States will this play a role in
the subsequent possible indictments
coming against Donald Trump and will
anybody who would even consider voting
for Donald Trump in 2024 even care about
what's in there I believe Trump was
correct when he said he could shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue
and not lose support
if he could shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue and not lose support is he going
to lose support because of some light
tax fraud or because he lied about his
wealth I don't think so and so it's been
a long fought battle
it's a matter of principle I believe at
this point where every other president
has released their tax returns other
than Donald Trump but will this actually
have consequences I find it really
really difficult to believe that it will
the next question is does it even matter
if Trump is destined to fail as the
potential Republican Presidential
nominee that's what I want to talk about
next it seems Donald Trump May to some
degree see the writing on the wall
that he may not win the 2024 Republican
primary we've already speculated as have
a number of different writers is Trump
even going to make it to the Republican
primaries or will a lack of support all
but force him to bail maybe citing other
interests maybe citing health issues
before a single ballot is even cast in
the 2024 Republican primary well there's
another possibility that Trump does run
for president but not within the
Republican primary and that seems to be
what he is now threatening to do
trumpist site encourages Donald to run
in a third party and he seems down
former president Donald Trump this is
from Rolling Stone who through his
nightmarish red cat back into the ring
and launched a third bid for the White
House shared an article Wednesday that
suggested he run as a third party
candidate posting on Truth social
essential the social media platform he
started after being booted from Twitter
Trump promoted an article from
conservative publication American
greatness staying true to the site's
unofficial role as a trump mouthpiece
Dan
that's difficult huh claimed that the
RNC can pretend Trump isn't loved by the
base anymore and that Trump is still
admired and even loved by those who
consider themselves ordinary Americans
compared Trump to the late president
Teddy Roosevelt
and suggested the idea of uh running
third party although gulleringtoner
admits that Trump running as a third
party candidate would likely meet a
similar fate to Woodrow Wilson he
declared his allegiance to the former
president Trump then reposted that I
guess you could say he re-trothed it and
mediaite reports Trump appears to
threaten third party run to split the
Republican party in half we want the
Republican party to destroy itself
Democrats seem unable to destroy it and
in fact sometimes make very strange
decisions that seem to almost prop it up
but it would be great if the Republican
Party destroyed itself and a third party
run by Donald Trump would Splinter the
party and it would absolutely undermine
its own chances in future elections now
a key factor to consider when we think
about this is
if Trump runs third party what impact
does that have on Republican voters what
would the average Republican voter think
because you have these Trump supporters
that are fiercely loyal to an almost
cult-like degree
they would certainly follow Trump if he
ran as a third party candidate that
takes votes away from the Republican
party and we'll talk in a moment about
why that is so important that splits the
conservative vote and opens the door for
Democrats even with a mediocre candidate
whoever the candidate ends up being to
win elections you could also see the
Republicans that are less cult-like but
are sort of in the well we're not I'm
I'm a conservative
but I'm not a trump person but I really
don't like Hillary I really don't like
Biden so I'm going to hold my nose and
vote for Trump that group that is
already sort of turned off by Trump's
rhetoric and by Trump's actions if Trump
runs third party that group of
Republicans will absolutely see it as
okay listen
I held my nose and I voted for Trump
over Hillary
and I voted for Trump over Biden but
that's because he was still within the
party I support now that Trump is
running third party that's too much for
me and I'll either stay home or just
vote for the Republican candidate even
if I know that it's an inevitability
that the with the vote split the
Democrat will win so it could also hurt
Trump with those reluctant Trump voters
that are really more Republicans than
they are Maga people and then there
could be the far-reaching consequences
for Republicans more broadly
um if you have the vote split in that
way and some people stay home and some
vote third party for Trump will they be
as eager to go out and vote for
Republican candidates for the House of
Representatives will these folks who are
kind of disgusted by what might happen
within the Republican party if Trump
runs third party will they go out and
eagerly vote for Republican Senate
candidates so Trump running third party
could be a delightful disaster for the
Republican party not only at the
presidential level but also down ballot
now the math of it for those who may not
know or who need a refresher is very
simple the Trump third party run all but
ensures a democratic victory in the
United States much to my dismay I don't
like the electoral college system but
the way you win in the United States is
you have to get a majority of the
Electoral College votes that means that
based on population each state has a
different number of votes or you might
call them points you need 270 points or
votes to win and the only way you get
those in most States is by the only way
you get any in Most states is by winning
the state's popular vote
if Trump were to run as a third party
candidate it is likely that he would
pull enough votes away from the
Republican candidate that the Republican
candidate would lose but that he would
also not get enough votes to win himself
meaning that a state that might have
gone
55-45 to Trump could end up going
something like you know just to make it
up here 45 percent to the Democrat
35 percent to Trump and 30 percent to
the Republican candidate Most states do
not have a 50 percent runoff threshold
Georgia does but not all states do
um and so Trump running third party
would all but seal the deal for the
eventual Democratic nominee when you
split the right-wing vote you make it
easier for Democrats to win and you make
it easy for Democrats to win with not
even a majority of the vote the real
question becomes is Trump dumb enough
not to understand the reality of the
math
and or is Trump narcissistic enough
to think that this is a good idea I hope
the answer is yes to both
and uh as I've said many times before
as an observer of politics I mean I'm
talking about myself now
um I don't care about the Democratic
party I'm not a Democrat I just vote for
whoever I think is going to do the best
job but I recognize the Dynamics the
party dynamics that exist I would love
to see the Republican Party damage
itself in exactly this way whether Trump
will do it whether the Republican party
has some Fail-Safe remains to be seen
let me know your thoughts and folks make
sure as we wrap up 2022 and get into
2023 make sure you were subscribed to
the YouTube channel it costs nothing it
affirms what we do and it helps us in
YouTube's algorithm we're fighting for 2
million YouTube subscribers it is not a
a level reached by too many Progressive
YouTube channels help us get there more
than 3 million of you regularly watch
our Clips but don't subscribe nothing
changes for you you can still eat
whatever food you like you can still
watch whatever shows you want you just
hit subscribe and you get us a little
bit closer to that 2 million threshold
we'll take a quick break and be back
right after this with the final show of
the year
over this holiday season please remember
how many families around the world are
living in extreme poverty our partner
give directly is the non-profit letting
you send cash directly to the world's
poorest households help the David
packman show reach our goal of fifteen
thousand dollars by the end of the year
at givedirectly.org Pacman a generous
give directly donor will match all
donations up to fifteen thousand dollars
to help us hit that goal so your
donation can have double the impact
giving in someone's name is a great last
minute holiday gift when organizations
give cash to families like this about 90
cents on the dollar get to the recipient
versus sometimes as little as 50 cents
on the dollar in terms of relative
impact with many other programs that's
why I reached out to give directly about
doing this with us give directly is how
you know every dollar you donate is
going to good use giving even a few
dollars can have a massive impact for
someone living on a dollar or two a day
help us reach fifteen thousand dollars
by December Thirty One and your donation
will be doubled go to give directly.org
Pacman the link is down below the David
packman show is of course a community
supported program we depend on your
support through something we call the
membership program much to the dismay of
many of our detractors you can sign up
at joinpakman.com and not only will you
get the show every day with no
commercials and either audio or video
forms you will also get the daily bonus
show
explosively produced after every single
day's podcast you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and use the coupon code
24 starts now to get yourself a discount
let's get to phone calls which aren't
really using the phone they're using
Discord you can find the Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord join the
waiting Lobby let's hear from some
people and remember you will not be
called on if your name is set to like a
nickname or something like that we need
your name and where you were calling
from let's start let's see if this works
we're going to try it we're starting
today with Kevin from Arlington let's
see if I can bring Kevin in
uh
uh and here is Kevin Kevin welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hi David I I actually didn't request to
speak uh so I've got to come up with
something oh my goodness okay you had it
looked like you wanted to be on today
so he could come up with a question okay
let's try instead
um we will try how about Chris from
Texas Chris from Texas welcome to the
program
uh you are on and I would love to hear
what's on your mind today
hey David so I guess one thing I was
wondering is that I guess with the new
Pokemon games being based off of Iberia
it always had me interested in now Latin
American culture so
one question I had is like for example
how do we Define Hispanic and Latino is
it by ethnicity or nationality oh we you
know we've looked at this before there's
two different camps on this issue
there's one camp that says Hispanic and
Latino are two completely different
things and there's another camp that
says this is more a semantic argument in
the modern era than it is really about
differences and you can use the terms
interchangeably
it depends on what your perspective is
one view is Hispanic means of Spanish
origin whereas Latino means from Latin
America which is basically like what's
Latin America
I guess Latin America is like the
Spanish-speaking countries in Central
and South America like a lot of people
say Brazil is not really Latin America
um it's I don't know it's it I don't
know how important it is to keep going
with that because is it is it
increasingly just like a semantic
question you know
yeah I guess because I was always
confused because I know you're from
Argentina right that's correct
and I know like one thing I was always
confused about with Argentina is that it
has a large Italian population which
kind of surprised me at first when I
learned about Argentina yeah so I was
kind of but
Italians aren't necessarily like Latino
though or Hispanic right well that's
another thing like why am I why am I his
Latino Or Hispanic in the United States
ethnically I'm an Ashkenazi Jew if my
family had moved from Ukraine to the US
rather than from Ukraine to Argentina to
the US my genetics would be exactly the
same my my ethnicity would be the same
but I would not be Hispanic but per the
way that the census is written I'm
Hispanic so I I don't know you know
these these things are sort of confusing
to some degree
yeah okay I understand thanks for the
call David all right Chris from Texas
thank you so much let's stay in Texas a
little bit and go to Rick from Southeast
Texas Rick from Southeast Texas what
just it's a Texas sword a day you know
Rick
Rick welcome
Rick you have self-muted you can unmute
yourself and then you'll be able to talk
to me
oh boy
Rick you there buddy
can you hear me yes I can
hey sorry about that David hey so um I
really wanted to call in about something
more more meta perhaps the origins
oranges of your show um so I've been I
was wondering you know with with your
show you I mean you're a one-man show
and respectfully you that's that's where
you should be but have you ever thought
about
um like other channels incorporating
other people into your show not saying
you should but it's never a thought or
or you know something like that I I
really want to see your your program you
know explode and and uh grow so what are
your thoughts on that yeah I mean listen
every program is different and sometimes
people will write to me and they'll say
you know David your program would be
better if you had an ensemble cast where
you had a whole bunch of people behind a
desk or whatever you know your show
would be better if you didn't take calls
or if it was all calls or if you did no
interviews or all interviews the thing
about it is every show is where it is
because of the way that it has been
produced and I am always very skeptical
of saying if I make this show more like
another show it will do better because
maybe that's not the way this show is
supposed to be so the way we produce the
show it sort of makes the most sense the
way we're doing it right now and and the
way that I do the sort of Ensemble thing
is I'll appear on other shows like next
month I'll be on the Patrick Bet David
show down in Florida or it might be in
Florida actually I forget where they
film and I've got some other appearances
coming up
um so that's the way I sample different
formats rather than like changing what
we do it's by appearing on other shows
that kind of do it differently if that
makes sense
absolutely no I agree and that I think
that's what makes her feel uh a little
bit more more specialized is you know
you kind of really get to know you and
and we hope that um we get to see more
from you soon I'm I'm a flada Florida
whatever you say transplant so I really
hope you enjoy the sun down there David
I'm looking forward to hopefully good
weather absolutely
of course thank you so much have a
wonderful day all right there is Rick
from Southeast Texas very very powerful
declaration and questions all of which
we love remember we're taking calls via
Discord if you want to be on you have to
have a nickname that includes your name
and location so I see a lot of one word
nicknames and stuff like that just it's
totally fine you just won't be called on
uh let's go next to Daniel in Tampa
Daniel in Tampa I would love to welcome
you on to the program
uh uh and here is Daniel joining us from
Tampa Florida
hey David can you hear me I can hear you
fine
wow actually I've been listening for two
years I just listened to everyone else's
talk for a while welcome
um yeah I actually have a couple
questions I know that you're from
Argentina but when did you move to this
taste because I don't hear an accent
like at all when you speak well I was
five years old and I jumped right into
English so uh yeah I mean other than not
knowing whether the word is anomaly or
anomaly on most words uh you know you
can't tell that that I'm not yeah I'm
essentially a native speaker right I
mean it's sort of a joke on the program
where I say I may be misunderstanding
Herschel Walker because I speak English
as a second language that's not really
why I can't understand Herschel Walker
you know what I mean
well I don't think anyone really
understands exactly exactly exactly
um I have one other question you and I
believe it was a May 2021 show oh boy
you I'm gonna yeah I want to try and
quote you you said that Argentina has a
very bad history of hiding non-white
argentinians
what do I have to Google that the Google
uh that to in order to read like oh I
don't think I did you're saying I said
of hiding non-white argentinians
yeah like the you said they have a bad
history of high of um something like
hiding it's not hiding well so there's
two different things okay let me just
let me break it down so there's two you
might be mixing two different things
Argentina has a history of hidden Nazis
in the country that's one thing
and Argentina has a horrible history in
turn like there's a reason why there's
almost no black people in Argentina and
it's a very very ugly history of racism
towards black people like years and
years and years ago
I I think that was the second one what
would I have to Google in order to
reappoint because that's the first time
I've ever heard of that history of
African immigrants in Argentina would
probably turn up a bunch of stuff I
would go to scholar.google.com I'm sure
there were papers there
okay but uh yeah that's uh only really
two questions I have for you all right
thanks things are things are good in
Tampa
uh yeah just a little bit cold still
going to the cold front it dropped down
like 30 in the weekend but so I'm gonna
I personally it's gonna go back up to
80. yeah yeah I hope the weather is good
when I get down there at the end of
January
oh yeah I'll probably be a lot warmer
then so beautiful all right my friend
thank you for the call
yep me too all right there we go uh I
don't know guys I think the new systems
is working pretty well here uh using
using the new system and Discord why
don't we the the one thing by the way if
moderators are listening it's hard to
see people's full nicknames because they
just go to ellipses and so it would be
interesting if there was some way
uh to to deal with that
um but we can uh we can sort of Workshop
that as we go let's go next to Casey
from Georgia if you please Casey from
Georgia welcome to the program
hey long time listener first time caller
thank you David thanks Casey welcome
yes I got a quick question I've been
seeing these ads on YouTube shine a
light on anti-Semitism yeah and it's
about I don't know if you're aware of it
but I agree with most of what they say
about like the model minority stereotype
and like people complimenting people how
that's actually anti-semitic but the one
thing I disagree with was that they said
that if you call Israel an apartheid
state that's inherently anti-semitic and
I was wondering what your opinion
um I don't think calling Israel an
apartheid state is inherently
anti-semitic no I mean the the the word
that's doing a lot of heavy lifting
there is inherently
I don't think it's inherently
anti-Semitic
all right well thank you that was my
question all right Casey from Georgia
very good I appreciate that uh let's see
where are we going next let's go to Sal
from mall I guess is it is it Malden
Mass or Marlboro oh from Malden South
from Malden welcome
you there sell
you're on live right now but no one can
hear you I'm guessing you have the wrong
audio device selected
and Sal is gone powerfully gone that was
wild let's invite Luke from Michigan to
speak today Luke from Michigan uh tell
me what is on your mind today I would
love to hear from you
hey David can you hear me yeah what is
it was that a chinchilla in the
background what was that
oh no that's my desk chair oh that's
your chair oh my good I thought it was
an animal
no
um
I'm a I'm a long time caller uh or not a
long time ago a listener first time
calling beautiful uh I didn't really
have a question oh to be fair I was just
kind of like listening in
um
well can I ask you a question
go for it how did you first stumble
across my content
um I want to say you were um
I saw some videos on YouTube and then
also I watched your live streams of like
the uh Trump rallies
oh okay so mostly basically YouTube was
the platform where you came across the
content
uh yeah that's correct and let me ask
you this this is just like kind of a
focus group
once you've found the content on YouTube
did you consume content anywhere else
like did you then say Oh I might follow
and watch your Tick Tock videos or are
you just within the YouTube Universe
basically
uh YouTube at first but then I I found
your Discord and twitch so I followed
you and subscribed on there as well
interesting all right very good well
anything I can do to improve the show
sir
no I I really enjoy it beautiful well
good to hear from you I appreciate it
you too thank you all right Luke from
Michigan very very important
um there is a um
there is an option to request to speak
also but I'm just kind of going around
and calling different people
so we can uh we can figure out how that
all is going to work let's go to
um where are we going here let's go to
Jessica from Indiana Jessica from
Indianapolis welcome to the program
hi thanks I've been like everyone else
I've been a long time listener but first
time caller pleasure to have you
uh two questions if that is okay sure
um So currently I'm introducing uh
Indiana local legislation
um as you might be aware of Indiana is
very much a red State and I'm currently
trying to introduce legislation to add
queer people okay crime protection laws
currently this is being drafted by um a
family friend of mine and state
representative Renee pack okay
um I believe to my understanding this it
is being drafted it has not been
introduced should I be preparing some
sort of like
speak to talk to the Indiana House when
the bill has been introduced I have
absolutely no idea unfortunately Jessica
I don't know the specifics of the
process there I just wouldn't be able to
advise you on that if there's a
possibility that you will be speaking it
would be your call whether you prepare a
speech
that's fair enough
um second question so you don't really
have that one
um let me see if I can try to find it
okay never mind I cannot find it
um why do you do you think it's a
coincidence that it always ends up being
the people that try to get queer books
and stuff of that nature banned from
schools that end up being um
caught having uh predatory issues when
it comes to like well it's not always
the case it's not always the case but
there is certainly a history of that
where some of the most fervent
homophobes end up being gay for example
but I I don't know that I have any broad
you know I'm not sure I have anything
else to say about it but we've covered a
number of cases in which it has happened
certainly
okay awesome that's all I really had all
right great to hear from you Jessica
from Indianapolis great to talk to you
um just so everybody knows there's
people trying to call me directly on
Discord uh you're just gonna get blocked
I just can't deal with that we have a
process and it's through the uh it's
through the waiting the waiting Lobby
um we do have a function that allows
people to request to speak and I don't
know why it's getting turned off it's
very very strange but let's try going to
Aubry from Wisconsin if we can Aubry
from Wisconsin welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hi can you hear me I can hear you fine
okay cool biased um okay sorry about
that I've spoken to you before like once
but okay beautiful sorry I have one
question for you
um I don't really know what to ask but I
was curious what is your views on like
this in cell culture because like I feel
like it it kind of Rose about with the
internet so like I'm like hella I'm the
old gen Z right
so like I just like turned 24 which is
super cringe but it's cringe to be 24
Aubry what does that mean
uh it's a color I'm like old right like
um I don't know like when I turned 25
Luxor I'm gonna get like I don't know
like so Aubry whenever you swear we have
to bleep it so please try to limit the
swearing and producer Pat please make a
note we've got a sensor lat that we've
got to bleep that Aubry um did you once
call in and even though you're from
Wisconsin it sounded like you had a Long
Island accent is that
yeah I know okay I remember you I
remember you
all right that's so cute romantic
um
no okay so I just want to know what your
view of like in cell culture is because
like these red pill people are cringe
and weird like um Kevin Samuels who like
always talked um down to women and like
um basically you know told them you know
you're never gonna find a man you're
gonna die at 35 because you think you
deserve someone better and then he ended
up dying Alone
um making love to a random woman you
know what I mean so I just want to do
your perspective on that
okay
um here's I don't know about the people
you're mentioning but here's my I
actually did a segment on the Wednesday
show about in cell culture here's the
thing in cells are often seen as uh
failures in society uh they are made fun
of and on and on and on and I think that
this is really the wrong approach
particularly because
it's part of the whole incel thing is
it's extremely anti-social in a way and
sometimes the incels end up committing
acts of violence like we've seen
elements of incel interwoven into
sometimes mass shootings and other
events so I believe we actually need to
reach out to incels and we need to
actually work with them and I don't know
whether it's therapy
groups or what it is but we need to
really provide the resources to both
develop skills and build confidence
because a lot of it is a self-fulfilling
prophecy where the in-cells lack
confidence and then they're made fun of
so they're even less confident and then
they can't get you know typically it's
like heterosexual men that women won't
talk to they get more depressed so we
need to we need to do something I think
it's it they're highly targeted and
often made fun of but I think we
actually need to be doing more to help
the incels
no okay okay I respect that right
completely yeah but
um
no no like listen right
um things like out of love and stuff
right
um like it's like these people who think
they deserve sucks because we women
please let me make a declaration there
is a small portion of people who think
the way to solve incel is to force women
to have sex with the incel men I do not
think that that's the solution I think
that's crazy
okay okay good I'm glad we cleared that
up okay
um I just want to say that
um to any men online who are listening
to this do not tell a woman she is an
ugly [ __ ] just because she does not
want to go out with you cringe weird
you're stupid all right Aubry very
important advice and useful hopefully to
many people in our audience uh or maybe
in in other audiences I don't know
necessarily to mine Aubry great to hear
from you again
[Music]
I don't know if Aubry who Aubry is
laughing at but a lot of laughing going
on there all right folks let's take a
very quick break we're not ending calls
so if you want to get on Just hold on
because we're going right back to the
Discord lines in a moment
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's continue hearing from our audience
we take calls via Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord you can join
the waiting Lobby and we have a number
of really great people who want to chat
because I tried to go to him earlier and
it failed let's try going back to Sal
from Malden Sal welcome are you equipped
to speak
yes David can you hear me yes I can Sal
welcome
oh awesome I'm so sorry about earlier
um I've been uh a fan uh watching since
2018 uh big big fan thank you
um I just had a uh question
um [ __ ] relating on
are there current topics
um
are there current topics within the left
that you feel that are not as talked
about or are considered new fields that
the left hasn't really uh tackled on
not so much I mean I think there's a
couple of issues that I would like to
see the left become sort of like revise
the default view and become more
informed about I would say GMO food and
new nuclear power would be two areas
where I think the left has been
reflexively and I'm talking about the
left broadly but not everybody within
the left anti-gmo even though there's no
evidence GMO foods are bad for you by
virtue of being GMO and reflexively
against nuclear power on the basis of
the dangers posed by 40 year old
technology which is not what would be
built today I'm not going around saying
let's eat as many GMOs as possible or
let's just switch 100 to nuclear power
I'm not saying either but sometimes in
conversations with some on the left
they're like oh GMOs or bad nuclear
power is bad and it's unsafe
um and I just those are two areas I've
researched somewhat extensively and I
just think a lot of the default
reactions from people on the left are
wrong on those issues
okay uh yeah definitely on the GMOs is
something that I've seen somewhat
divided I've actually seen
um I'm actually a very uh Pro GMO
um but I've actually agreed with people
on the right on some of these issues
when it comes to
um using uh GMOs to whether they see it
more as an economics uh a benefit in the
economics I see it more as just uh being
more efficient with food
um but I I find it at GMOs is something
that the left hasn't really um I guess
uh taking a
deep deep dive into yeah I don't know
that it's like the number one issue that
everyone's like I gotta learn more about
GMOs I think there's just a lot of
people who are like they must be bad I
don't know it sounds bad genetically
modified can't possibly be good
yes and off the top of my head I've
heard that in some countries in Europe
some GMOs are banned so either banned or
bad
I guess banned oh I believe was I I may
be misquoting but
is that a general view outside the
United States that GMOs should be banned
I don't know enough about attitudes
towards GMO outside the U.S so I
wouldn't be able to say it's really an
empirical question I just don't have the
answer offhand but it would be
interesting to see
oh okay
um and I just had one quick question
please uh so
I need a lawyer for my lathes because
this lawsuit is is just taking a huge
toll do you have any recommendations for
any lawyers I don't I know that your
machines are under threat from Mike
pillow but he's going to be distracted
being RNC chair soon so I think your
lathe is going to be okay
all right thank you so much for the call
very nicely executed I appreciate that
uh we have so many folks here who want
to chat today let's try Lily from
Nebraska Lily from Nebraska welcome to
the program
hello can you hear me yes
all right cool I've been a long time
listener but this is my first time
calling in well welcome
so um in regards to what you what you
have stated previously about how it's
difficult for many people in the U.S uh
to leave the country if um
if uh the country were to be too far
gone yeah
um in terms of I don't know a better way
to say that but
um I actually have found a very good way
for people in high school to
um to potentially leave
um the country for college like I've
experienced a very easy process
um with uh moving to Canada uh for
University and it's actually pretty
affordable and so
um
I mean it's just it's the same thing as
the U.S college application process
except yeah a little bit more of like
you need to apply through immigration
but right with that I think a whole
bunch of like people who are under 18
years old can consider that if that's
useful for people of a certain age I
have family going to school in Canada as
U.S citizens and yes uh and there is a
path it's not super easy to just be like
I want to move to Canada now I'm going
to work in Canada forever but there is a
path where if you get into school in
Canada then once you're there you can be
authorized to work and then if you work
in Canada for a period of time then
you're authorized to actually get
permanent status and I don't know if
it's like permanent residency or
citizenship but that's a great path for
people of a certain age
yeah I I know that obviously does not
apply to people who are already past
that age right but yeah for in my
specific circumstance I'm planning on
attending the University of Alberta for
the next four years okay and I also
found out that people who are attending
college in uh in um in Canada actually
are eligible for the Canadian rates for
University for graduate school
um and that's fantastic that is
significantly cheaper than anywhere that
you can go for the US yes um
typically true yeah there's no such
thing as in-stay or out of state or in
Province or out of province in Canada
it's the same rate for everyone and so
yeah I just wanted to get that out to
people who are planning are who are
looking for ways to get out of the U.S
all right Lily thank you very much for
the suggestion
yeah thank you
um and
I'll see you later all right Lily from
Nebraska thank you very very much let's
try Nate from Rhode Island to see what's
going on in Rhode Island Nate welcome to
the program what is on your mind today
Nate
hey David how you doing doing well
so I just had a quick question for you
are you interested in you uh thought
about paying your mods before or now
sorry have I thought about paying for
Miles I like for my car lease yeah have
you thought about paying your Discord
mods as an employee slash independent
contractor type thing oh not really no I
mean people volunteer and you know
there's tons of people that want to do
it and it's sort of a labor of love but
we've not we don't you know we have
moderators on YouTube I think we've got
like 20 15 on Twitch there's a bunch on
Discord Reddit Etc that's a lot of
people total it's really just if it's
sort of more of like a hobby type thing
we I don't really see it as like an
employment sort of thing
that's fair enough and then my other
question was um did you know when you're
home stated in New York that's where
you're out of now right yep
um CVS I actually just found out is
violating sick time laws so I'll be
contacting your Department of Labor to
see what that's all about oh look look
forward to that well I have zero
influence over the New York Department
of Labor I want to make clear to you
Nate and so I will be fully recused from
that action
we'll keep in contact and you'll
hopefully know when the time comes all
right uh should I avoid New York CVS's
for the time being
uh absolutely no I'm just kidding maybe
Walgreens is the way to go I don't know
I don't know what their practices are
you know
yeah
who knows they're probably the same
they're all they're all big com all big
companies are like that they'll break
into law in some way most likely all
right Nate let us know how the lawsuit
goes okay we'll do have a nice day there
is Nate uh with extremely litigious
maybe one of the most litigious viewers
I would actually say interestingly
enough
um all right let's go next to Sarah
Sarah Bara I guess I'm not exactly sure
Sarah
Hi how are you I'm doing well
okay um so I have a question regarding
information and
um debating like uh send information so
for example when we're debating against
conservatives yes right about let's say
Donald Trump's
um 17 new indictments or or his possible
fate when it comes to gen six
um how do you deal with people who just
say oh no no that's all a lot that that
never happens that's that's all your
information is a lie all your sources
are not true but my sources are true how
do you debate against that if they are
really in such bad faith saying all your
sources aren't accurate and all of mine
are that's really really extreme and so
I don't even know that I would mess with
that now I think oftentimes it's not
quite so it's extreme it's I don't
really believe that you you'd say well
why not
well I don't trust the source okay what
sources do you trust how do you
determine what sources are trustworthy
what evidence from which source could I
present you that would change your mind
about whether this particular thing is
or isn't true you have to start with a
Socratic method of questioning to try to
establish how they even determine what
they can believe in general but when
someone just if it's really as bad as
every Source you're looking at it can't
be trusted you got to look only at my
sources I would honestly not even waste
my time with people that extreme
yeah I'll say I agree with that
especially when um they're acting in
such bad faith that it's almost
impossible to have like a good like an
actual conversation without them just
like um
setting aside every single
um uh source that you have 100 and by
the way we we have a guide that's free
for how to manage a lot of these
conversations with people the guide is
at davidpackman.com guide I'm not
selling anybody anything it's just
because you brought it up it's like an
eight or ten page paper it's a guide
it's free and it gives you a lot of
techniques actually for how to talk to
these people
oh that's cool I'll definitely be
looking into that yeah um thank you so
much for answering my question my
absolute pleasure thank you so much for
the call that will do it for today but
the new system on Discord has been an
unmitigated success ladies and gentlemen
so thank you to everybody who helped set
it up in particular the moderators and
we will take calls again and we will use
a system like this one next week thank
you very much
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's do the final Friday mailbag of
2022 I know we are turning a corner that
in 2023 the emails I get will be
positive constructive not anti-Semitic
who am I kidding we know that that's not
going to change it probably will get
worse all right let's get a mix of
things that came in remember info
davidpackman.com is where you can email
we will also sometimes feature a message
from Facebook or maybe something that
comes in on the YouTube channel or
whatever the case may be I heard from a
gentleman and you be the judge as to
whether they really are a gentleman who
said to us on Facebook you are stupid
Fox News is number one for a reason
that's true I don't know that we would
agree on what that reason is but okay
Fox News is number one for a reason I
bread Punk your y o u r a pace of s
you're a pace and wrong you're of course
going on to say you voted for by Dawn
b-i-d-o-n that's enough to prove your
capital s stupid
f u Jesus is coming for you send you
into Bernie lava cross Jesus
so this is a commentary about a
disagreement this person has with me
over Economic Policy as I'm sure you can
tell very productive very actionable and
very much welcoming debate rather than
shutting it down extremely important
Dwayne also wrote to me and I'm going to
be careful with my pronunciation here
Wayne wrote To Me fuke you are pronouns
now this Dwayne said your y o u
apostrophe re
two emails in a row first guy uses the
wrong your Dwayne also uses the wrong
wrong you're saying I am pronouns
apparently
fuke your pronouns you never did answer
when I asked is psychology damage for a
girl like your daughter to see a boy in
a dress
it clearly is to me
to a dumb Progressive I don't know
I'm doing I'm struggling and listen I
know English is my second language maybe
it's my my language limitation that
makes it difficult to understand this I
think what Dwayne is asking is is it
psychologically damaging for a girl like
my daughter to see a boy in a dress
you know I think you could show my
daughter just about any clothing item on
anyone
and she wouldn't care she doesn't know
what's going on that I can tell you
um no Dwayne has real problems and of
course fuke you are pronouns
it could be the name of a band quite
frankly fuke you are pronouns and I
would encourage a band uh to pick up
that name but Wayne continuing not to
contribute productively to the
conversation Jen wrote in about Kerry
Lake's election trial which fortunately
has concluded with the lawsuit in the
trash which is where it should be Jen
wrote quote hi David huge fan of your
show I just moved to the Phoenix area
from Sacramento California a local news
channel here is doing a live stream of
the Kerry Lake election trial is what
they're calling it my question to you is
what is this trial going to solve or
uncover well it'll solve nothing and it
will uncover no wrongdoing and that's
exactly what happened Jen continues it
doesn't seem helpful in restoring trust
in the election that's not what it's for
the Maga crowd will say the election was
stolen if Lake isn't governor and of
course Hobbes will be the next governor
of Arizona I'd love your thoughts on
this yeah Jennifer is completely right
which is of course the trial didn't
overturn the election results because
there's no evidence to suggest the
results should be overturned so
absolutely the trumpists will argue as
they are
that the trial itself was corrupt and so
even though now there's been a trial and
the judge said you haven't actually
provided evidence of a stolen election
so we're going to dismiss this now it is
that decision that is biased and the
court that is biased and um it's uh this
is what we call unending skepticism
skepticism is good
healthy skepticism is good hey we should
be satisfied that elections were uh
handled properly oh there are claims
from Arizona Let's explore the claims
none of the voting machines worked okay
truth is a few tabulators briefly didn't
work even the RNC has been satisfied
that the election was not rigged all
right so the tabulator thing probably
isn't good well people weren't allowed
to vote you look at the affidavits the
affidavits say people who showed up
after the polls close weren't allowed to
vote oh well that's the law if you show
up after the polls close if you're not
in line at the time the polls close
you're not allowed to vote that so we
were skeptical we evaluated the claims
there's no evidence for them we now move
on the unending skepticism is how
conspiracy theorists end up in a rabbit
hole out of which they cannot get and
that's exactly uh what we saw in Arizona
Peter wrote in and said why the career
change why did you go from being a
English teacher I guess Peter maybe
should have been in my class A English
teacher to a political hack now of
course
I I was never an English teacher maybe
Peter has me confused
with some other host I don't I don't
know
um but there's a lot of people in my
audience
painfully confused about what is
happening on this show Brian wrote in
about gun deaths and said David in
discussing the subject of guns and child
deaths you mentioned the instances when
someone says limiting clip capacity
wouldn't have made a difference in this
specific incident
tell them no maybe not but it might make
a difference in the next one yeah this
is a good point you know as I've said
before I have put forward 10 to 12
suggestions for reducing gun violence
and no one suggestion would solve every
problem nor prevent every shooting the
suggestions are widespread and Broad it
includes eliminating any loophole that
allows the transfer of a gun without a
background check as an example
limiting clip capacity preventing people
under certain ages from buying certain
guns no one of and other things no one
solution no one change would be a
solution to every uh a shooting but
altogether they would make a difference
in total and isn't it still good to
reduce gun deaths even if you can't
prevent every gun deaths isn't it better
to prevent some particularly when you
can do so without placing any undue
burden on gun owners oh a background
check okay and without violating the
Second Amendment to the Constitution
seems worth doing to me and Brian has a
good addition which is well maybe it
wouldn't have prevented that one but it
might prevent the next one I like it
Garrett Rhoden seemingly obsessed with
my party identification now as many of
you know I'm not a Democrat and what I
mean by that is it's just a binary thing
have I ever been registered as a
Democrat no have I ever donated to the
Democratic party no I'm not a Democrat
okay Garrett wrote in and says you are a
Democrat hi David can you just Embrace
that you're a Democrat I saw you once
slightly rant about how you're a Social
Democrat I don't even know what that
means I mean you can try to explain I
don't think you could so
Garrett's already confused
Democrat capital D Democrat which is
what he's talking about is a political
party
social democracy is a political ideology
it's not even one or the other these are
different categories of things now some
countries have a Social Democratic party
when I say I'm a Social Democrat I'm not
talking about an allegiance to a party
I'm saying my ideology is I'm a
progressive Social Democrat in terms of
party membership I'm not a member of the
democratic party two different things
okay
Garrett goes on it would be like well I
believe in a strong social safety net
free regulated Enterprise Bravo we all
do you seem like by all plain
definitions in U.S politics a Democrat
so just be one you're not special unless
you have some example as a
self-subscribed Social Democrat who
you're a huge supporter for who is that
who is the big politician you love who
is not a Democrat and if you say who it
is please tell me their policies are any
better than just a regular Democrat I'm
pretty sure you are just a Democrat
which is fine but live your life cheers
Garrett from New York City listen Gary I
don't know why you're so obsessed with
my party identification but I can't say
it any other way and if you're not
understanding I don't know what to do I
am not a member of the Democratic Party
the way I describe My Views is that I am
a progressive Social Democrat which is a
regulated form of capitalism
now everybody's policing my speech geez
um okay last one
hey instead of the December 24th
donation thingy
can't you sell David pakman nfts I
seriously would pay 99 to help support
your great Channel but I want to see you
in an astronaut suit please I know
instead of doing the charity fundraiser
we did
I should have done what Trump did which
is I should have simply offered digital
trading cards of myself in all sorts of
strange and bizarre outfits I'm sure
they would have sold out in a day just
like Trump's uh but no we're not doing
that we did the charity fund Drive
and I think it was the right decision
we've got a great bonus show for you
today get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com not only will you get
access to the bonus show you will also
get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show every day hours
before we publish them for everybody
else it's cheap it's quick it's easy
it's a great way heading into the new
year to support Independent Media that
you believe deserves support join
pacman.com you can use the coupon code
24 starts now and we will see you on
today's bonus show
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors please donate to
give directly the non-profit letting you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest families when you donate to give
directly.org Pacman a generous donor
will match your donations up to fifteen
thousand dollars makes a perfect holiday
gift help us reach fifteen thousand
dollars by the end of the year using the
link below